vaches 206 là quand même
c'est violent allez-y son père l'a forcé
à manger les clémentines sur son sexe
ses l'inceste
il l'a sodomisée seulement après il
allait à la pharmacie acheter de la
vaseline et je voudrais savoir parce
qu'il fait rire david avec clémentine
célarié
c'est parce qu'elle s'appelle clémentine
henry parce que je pensais que tu n'es
pas d'accord et oui mais voyez mais son
père l'a forcé à manger des clémentines
sur son sexe vous êtes marais non je me
suis marré puisque j'ai entendu les gens
rigolaient parce que je me suis dit
tiens déjà plus continuer voilà donc
c'est vrai que l'on rigole des fois
souvent de choses on ne comprend pas
c'est vrai non mais c'est un sujet quand
même des pieds que vous êtes arrivé sur
le plateau vous n'avez pas sourit même
ri une seule fois ci qu'est ce qui vous
fait rêver
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire la question
de ne vous n'avez pas un rythme c'est
invraisemblable ce genre de questions
vous fait rire et rêver enfin voyez ces
gens ne seront que voilà donc ça c'est
la dernière fois qu'il est venu dans
l'émission et vous avez été méchante
avec linda hardy du coup à départ alors
vous dites alors dans votre bouquin en
parlant de sa clémentine célarié menti
fier d'avoir à se justifier à tellerie
angola vue pas le téléspectateur le
public a ri david hallyday arrive ils
ont ri après que thierry ardisson a lu
pages de santis et c'est ce qu'on vient
de voir et vous continuez tous on rit
maintenant ils sont gênés maintenant
génique ils sont les invités fixe le
petit écran qu'ils ont chacun dans
l'invention qui leur permet de tamiser
le réel par sa représentation
clémentine j'ai ri parce que les gens
ont ri parce que je pensais qu'il
pensait à moi
david hallyday on rigole souvent des
choses qu'on comprend pas personne ne
relève et d'émission continue
linda hardy la coanimatrice qu'est ce
qui vous fait rêver crise
donc vous aviez jeter un vrai froid
voulait dire avec ce passage
oui parce que vous leur avez demandé
pourquoi ils ont ri c'est vrai que la
réaction humaine devant devant une
phrase comme c'est sûr que c'est une
réaction humaine est une réaction
naturelle je pense à l'action sociale
c'est pour l'action humaine se fasse est
vraiment un truc quand on dit une phrase
qu'elle a que la crudité de celles que
j'ai cité de votre précédent livre donc
s'appeler l'inceste
les gens rient ce une façon de se
défendre devant une telle violence
exactement combien les gens ont tort de
se défendre parce qu'à force de se
défendre
il ne protège pas les autres et c'est
toujours les mêmes qui sont dans les
places qui sont à la place d'être
attaqué et ça suffit quoi j'en ai marre
de ça vient alors le livre dont on parle
depuis cinq minutes c'est celui là donc
c'est christine angot et c'est chez
stock
alors vous raconter la sortie de
l'inceste votre livre précédent donc qui
a fait certains scandales on peut le
dire non d'une certaine façon disons que
c'est tellement disproportionné c'est
tellement papa papa de pas dans les
chiffres de pour moi la première de voir
un livre dont je pensais le titre
complètement rédhibitoire comme ça de
faire quand je veux le voir comme ça se
vendre de le voir la maison de la presse
où il y avait un truc complètement
décalé si vous voulez c'est l'histoire
quitter la ville des gens qui sont pas à
leur place c'est à dire nous tous c'est
à dire c'est le fait que un livre ne
soit pas sa place
une personne n'est pas à sa place vous
n'êtes pas à votre place
personne personne n'était à sa place et
effectivement tout le monde change tout
le temps
c'est comme on n'est pas à notre place
on n'arrête pas de se piquer les places
s'est scindé oury bah oui la branche pas
parce que c'est un terminal ouest génial
c'est que moi j'ai lu son livre 1 et
elle fait un bouquin sur la sortie de ce
style dans précédemment sur facebook
font en lisant ce livre si je sais tu
fais pas je entendu parler christine di
meco sinon je te claque
et je sais qu'elle va faire par la suite
un livre sur la sortie de ce livre là et
que je serai dedans annoncé un sur deux
vous parlez de bouillon de culture de
passage à bouillon de culture donc que
le masque et la plume sur france inter
vous été traitée de [ __ ] quand même
c'est là mon masque et la plume non
c'est rare que les écrivains soit soit
traitée de [ __ ]
alors qu'en fait il devrait l'être tout
le temps vu que c'est vraiment ce que
les gens d'accord jeudi sur le non c'est
pas ça ne s'est pas la prostitution mais
en revanche c'est ce que les gens
pensent et c'est mépriser les écrivains
c'est comme les acteurs c'est divin
c'est quelqu'un qui se met à nu devant
tout le monde donnait de l'argent c'est
bien c'est bien la prostitution
non parce que c'est ce sens j'étais
d'accord claude non non je sais pas
c'est évidemment pas vous savez
je pense dire que c'est pas c'est pas ça
s'est passé pas se mettre à nu c'est
mettre à nu les autres et c'est pas pour
gagner de l'argent parce que sinon je
pensais vraiment vous parler des
articles qui sont sortis à l'époque des
ragots et en gros c'est un peu la
tragédie de passe comme ça qu'on peut le
voir la tragédie un peu de candide au
pays du showbiz sort d'un seul coup vous
êtes mêlée comme ça c'est vrai un gros
succès c'est la tragédie
face à la tragédie en tout cas celle
aventures de de faire un chemin c'est
quand on fait un chemin et ben il ya des
trucs qui se passent
voilà c'est ça alors je vous ai quand
même donné une certaine stature
médiatique vous déclarez danger lui seul
dans paris match
désormais tous paris match et ce qu'ils
ont fait mais c'est à lui de le dire moi
je lis donc moi moi je vis dans paris
match je me dis quand même en gohelle
elle se la pète un peu comme on dit en
parlant de michael mais vous vous dites
dans match désormais tout ce que je dit
ou écrit atteint des proportions énormes
voulait peut-être pas dit mais c'est ce
qui est écrit dans le journal
maintenant on m'écoute ce que je dis
c'est que pendant dix ans j'ai publié
des livres et que et qu'il n'y avait
aucune résonance médiatique qui voit là
il y avait absolument aucun écho bon ce
qui s'est passé effectivement l'année
dernière c'est juste un changement par
rapport à un volume sonore c'est tout
alors votre livre alors on découvre en
lisant ce bouquin très intéressant le
petit monde le milieu littéraire
on voit par exemple commencer le bouquin
sur cette phrase vous êtes obsédé par
les ventes ont commencé le bouquet en
disant je suis 5e de l'ex mais je ne
suis pas obsédé par les ventes
je suis j'ai besoin de dire ce que c'est
que de faire un trajet un moment il ya
tout un truc aussi sur ce que sait par
exemple que le trajet du lis je dis que
ce trajet décrire par exemple eh ben
c'est aussi de prendre la mer sur un
bateau et
et ces trajets de très belles avec
ulysse cela dit quand on est le bouquin
on est tenu au courant page par page des
ventes à l'unité près hélas cette
question prend un bâton on a besoin de
regarder à quelle vitesse le vent va
tourner c'est pareil vous êtes combien
claude sur l'a10 l'express je suis pas
essayer document vous êtes premier bain
c'est bien je vais mettre dans votre
prochain livre je suis premier
l'emballage de luxe mais c'est pas une
aventure littéraire
non pas ça l'enjeu la gueule toi vous
calculez l'argent que vous gagnez vous
dites par exemple ça me rapporter 700
mille francs à l'orge est mensualisé ses
700 mille francs va me les donner voilà
il faut que j'aurais rembourser
d'aventuré spa 700 mille francs
on va me donner c'est marrant je vais
vous raconter vraiment le quotidien je
dis pas que c'est inintéressant
j'ai dit que c'est inédit en touche je
ne le dit voilà je ne dis pas parce que
je pense que c'est intéressant je le dis
parce que et des trucs qui sont dans la
vie et elle c'est la vie qui débouche
dans l'écriture c'est la vue qui est
nourri une écriture c'est la vie qui va
vers l'écriture il ya ce type que vous
dézinguer chez pivot qui est un mec de
chez gallimard et qui s'appelle
laclavetine après avoir tué la clape
c'est laclavetine appelons le comme ça
sollers modiano et p&o elle ne l'appelle
plus toute façon que comme ça après
l'émission il est parti quinze jours à
l'étranger son éditrice n'a pas pu aller
dîner avec lui après l'émission le père
dont elle ne voulait pas manger avec le
patron de gallimard et est en rage il a
dit après ça qui peut avoir envie
d'envoyer des manuscrits
c'est le pire représentant de chez
gallimard mois après et là c'est vous
vous passez devant une librairie
s'appelle la une il y avait sa photo il
m'attirait j'ai mais son regard mecs
venaient de le dézinguer à mort je me
disais on aurait pu être à man au lieu
de s'entretuer en public
si je m'étais écouter j'aurais téléphoné
et j'aurais proposé qui prendre un café
alors qu'évidemment c'est plus possible
du tout c'est assez joli ça vous l'avez
écrasé le mec et en sortant vous avez
cette espèce de compassion voyant son
portrait dans une librairie à saint
germain c'est pas bien
pardon c'est pas bien finalement si
c'est bien mais non tous c'est être
capable de compassion pour ce type
vous êtes là certainement attendre à une
certaine pitié paul c'est difficile je
veux dire moi je suis j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut venir la télévision et puis
on n'y arrive pas là quand vous citez
sas et c'est une horreur pourquoi mais
parce que c'est moi je c'est pas mon
livre pas de votre éditeur aussi jean
marc roberts qu'on a traité de souteneur
parce que comment vous traiter de [ __ ]
on l'a traité de souteneur et qui la lui
en tous les cas on lui a reproché de
faire une opération marketing avec vous
oui ça vous a beaucoup fait souffrir ça
on vous a dit télérama devisé ce qu'il
préfère un autre auteur qui tout ce
qu'il faut ça me fait souffrir tout ce
qui est faux ça me fait souffrir ce
qu'on est en train de faire là c'est
faut donc ça me fait souffrir
qu'est ce qu'on fasse que je lis des
extraits non je ne sais pas on s'arrête
de parler de votre livre va peut-être si
vous voulez ouais moi je veux bien moi
j'ai prévu un certain nombre d'extraits
parce que je pense sa plainte est resté
spectateur maintenant si ça vous
intéresse pas ou plus tard était l'autre
qu'est ce t'en pense rien si elle me le
disait claude problèmes n'ont soit pas
[ __ ] non plus je dirais et si on crée
une bonne ambiance sont sur place et
hyper difficile et hyper difficile de
parler des livres
moi je crois que la meilleure façon de
parler des villans lire des passages
parce que c'est ridicule de cette taille
d'un livre je préfère en rire des
passages moins ça vous gêne que je lis
des passages de vote qui va la
télévision j'arrête
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'on peut
être quatre touristes bouquin ça donne
pas envie d'être évincé donne envie
d'aller travailler en usine et ben voilà
alors là je suis d'accord mais
évidemment ce que si c'est ça c'est pas
mais bien sûr c'est pas un rêve d'être
écrivain non pas contre votre bouquin
voilà on en reste là pour dimanche je
voulais d'accord mais c'est vrai ce que
disait baffie tout à l'heure dans vous
allez écrire en 98 un livre s'appelle
sujet angot et vous revenez vous
reveniez sur la réception médiatique du
précédent
et là vous revenez sur la réception
médiatique du précédent on sait quoi que
vous allez faire une fois sur deux comme
ça un livre qui parle de la section
chasse pas dans ces cas
jeudi que les dix que la vie en train de
la vie c'est tout à fait un livre est le
suivant vous raconter la sortie du
précédent
je ferai comme vous voulez c'est un
paradoxe
il y en a un autre si c'est que vous
avez vendu 50 mille exemplaires de votre
du livre inceste j'ai vu des interviews
vous sembliez être étonné en disant
c'est pas normal que ça se vende moi moi
j'étais étonné en voyant un auteur du
temps d'expliquer que c'est pas normal
que son bouquin se vendent et vous fait
alors de bouquins et vous dites cela
c'est pas normal qu'ils ne se vendent
pas ne se vend pas celui là alan suis là
ils vont pas là est ce que vous voulez
que c'est lui la suivante non il se
vendra pas et vous êtes étonné moi je
vois rien je vous l'avais dit je vous ai
vue oui non mais ça serait bien pour le
livre mais pas pour vous on peut pas
dire que j'ai choisi des rares vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas cinquième
réseau express avec son nom là il se
passe rien vous êtes déçu oui pensez
encore être nounou non mais bien sûr je
suis déçu je n'ai pas de critiques qui
sont pas très sympas
elles sont même très dur il ya benoît
duteurtre ans je reste dans paris match
24 tirs
mais je vais la lire alors ça veut dire
si moi je dis juste la dernière phrase
il dit que c'est un produit son contenu
rango n'existe que par ses postures elle
se sent obligé de revenir aussi vite
donc un an après de peur qu'on
s'aperçoive qu'elle n'existe pas yves
uni il vous ni
tout fait quoi quand vous lisez ça le
matin en me réveillant vous voulez que
je vous dise oui moi je me suis dit que
c'était une trahison de plus dans la
mesure où j'ai fait cette interview avec
paris match et patrick besson 2 patrick
besson et va c'est surtout pop paris
match m'a demandé de faire cette
interview très bien vous vous allez
comme ça naïvement vous dit tiens je
vais répondre aux questions que cette
petite me pose il est pas mal hein mais
ça fait rien j'ai quand même essayé de
répondre et ça se passe bien parce
qu'avec patrick besson ça se passe bien
ce rapt est ce que ça se passe c'est bon
c'est intéressant c'est vraiment très
très dur parce que on n'est pas contre
la main au cul et l'on bosse à leur jeu
les chauffer avec cette histoire de
femme qui adore ça qui est pas fidèle et
tout ça l'a perturbé voulait dégraisser
le mammouth rien à l'arrivée à
dégraisser avec en gros oui et puis à
partir de là il a essayé de me draguer
mais j'en veux pas vous pouvez pas
savoir ce qui aura marqué dans le
prochain bouquin
voilà et est ensuite revenu à la pétoche
peut-être pas de prochain bouquin stop
ou encore
un stop pourquoi christine je crois pas
vraiment ça m'amuse pas quoi et pourquoi
on s'amusait bien nouma moi non mais les
parties un nord sera de ma faute c'est
claude moi je ne suis pour rien là
dedans
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux